Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 277, wo wir uns mit etwas beschäftigen, wo ich als Radiomensch fast ein Herzkars mal bekommen habe, aber dann hat sich letztlich herausgestellt, es ist doch nur eine digitale Infrastruktur, die kaputt ist und damit beschäftigen uns heute und haben uns, apropos kaputt machen, dazu vor allen Dingen Leute ausgeladen, die das wirklich als Namen auch mitbringen, nämlich vom Team Zerforschung, Karl und Lilith.
Hey, danke für die Einladung.
Und vom NDR, nein falsch, und eine freie Journalistin, die für den NDR arbeitet und an dem kaputt macht Dingen, über das wir heute sprechen, auch beteiligt ist, nämlich Svea. Hallo und guten Tag.
Hi, danke für die Einladung.
So, und wir sprechen heute über DIGAS. Und warum habe ich da ein Herzinfarkt bekommen, das Radio Mensch? Weil DIGAS ist ein fürchterlich altes Schnittprogramm, was an die früheren Zeiten des beginnenden Computerzeitalters war, wenn ich denke so, was ist denn jetzt los, wenn so ein altes Schnittprogramm eine so fürchterliche Reaktion und ein Tagesschauartikel auslöst, aber dann war es doch nur eine oder mehrere digitale Gesundheitsanwendungen. Und was das ist, wie man das macht und was daran kaputt war, das klären wir heute. Und dann fange ich sozusagen in meiner Eigenschaft als Moderator mit der einfachsten Frage an, die mir dazu einfällt, nämlich wer, was oder wie ist eigentlich ein DIGAS?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie viele Minuten arbeitet so jemand für 75 Euro?
Wenn man überlegt, wie viele Stunden in der Regel bei uns schon reingeflossen sind, bis so ein Report überhaupt verschickt wird. Weil ich meine, bei uns ist das ja so, ja, jemand findet diese Sicherheitslücke bei der Forschung. Und dann schreiben wir die gemeinsam auf. Und dann lesen da noch mal mehrere Menschen drüber. Und dann checken wir das alles noch drei- viermal gegen. Also wir reden da wahrscheinlich von 40, 50 Stunden selbst für eine relativ einfache Lücke, die in Zeit da reinfließt, bis wir überhaupt unseren Report rausschicken. Also zumindest, wenn man die zusammenrechnet von den mehreren Menschen, die daran arbeiten. Also das ist so die Dimension, die wir da, glaub ich, regelmäßig irgendwie erreichen. Bloß die Zeit, die wir halt einfach nicht finden. Also deswegen, das ist schon ein ziemlicher Aufwand, den wir so machen. Und wir fühlen uns dann halt schon so ein bisschen verarscht, wenn jemand sagt, ja, aber wir haben die doch irgendwie entlohnt. Und dann sehen wir so, ja, okay.
Ja, ich fand es halt, also ich fand es nicht ganz transparent geschrieben, weil unter Entlohnung irgendwie 75 Euro auf dem Patreon-Account. Lieber transparent halt schreiben. Ich bin Fan geworden und habe gespendet. Ich fand das jetzt ein bisschen bemerkenswert an dieser, sagen wir mal an dieser Antwort oder an der Stellungnahme. Sonst waren aber die Hersteller schon so, dass sie eben geschrieben haben, ja, wir haben das schnell gelöst, wir haben schnell in den Griff gekriegt. Aber ich würde sagen, auch sehr typisch, ich sag mal PR-Strategie. Also, red nicht über das Problem im Sinne von, welche Daten sind abgeflossen? Na ja, wir haben es schnell gelöst. Und so kann man sich dann so eine Antwort auch vorstellen. Ich habe dann, wie gesagt, noch ein längeres Interview auch geführt. Klar, wie die sich natürlich auch rechtfertigen, und da kommen wir vielleicht noch einmal kurz zurück auf dieses Thema Preise und Geld, ist natürlich, dass die sagen, okay, wir müssen halt diese Studien durchführen. Wir haben halt da, was diesen Teil angeht, hohe Entwicklungskosten. Und ich glaube, damit meinen die nicht das Programmieren der App, sondern tatsächlich halt, um halt für diese Zertifizierung zugelassen werden. Und wir forschen ja noch weiter. Also wir entwickeln die App ja weiter. Und dieses Entwickeln, das kostet ja Geld. Und deswegen ist es gerechtfertigt. Oder jetzt bei dieser App war es so, die haben ungefähr drei, also haben sie uns gesagt, die hätten 300 zahlende Kunden im Moment. Und so haben wir eher gesagt, im Moment machen wir mit der App noch gar keinen Gewinn. Weil eigentlich haben wir noch gar nicht so viele Leute, die die auch vom Arzt verschrieben bekommen. Ich wollte es nur hier auch zur Transparenz einmal sagen, um halt auch so die Stimme oder die Stellungnahme der Anbieter wiederzugeben.
Wobei das, also da muss ich noch einmal hinterher, auch natürlich etwas schön gerätet ist. Weil ja, es stimmt, es sind 300 Kundinnen, die das als DiGA haben, aber die App existiert halt weiter. Und es ist auch, oder existierte vorher schon und hat halt auch andere Betätigungsfelder. Also der Hersteller vertreibt auch irgendwie eine App für medizinische Zulassungsstudien irgendwie. Was wahrscheinlich der gleiche Datensatz war, auf den wir Zugriff hatten. Und das waren dann deutlich mehr als 300. Das waren dann auch, glaube ich, wieder so einige 1000 bis wenige 10.000.
Ja, ich glaube 12.000 waren es, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, das war so die Dimension auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ich habe noch eine Detailfrage an die Zerforschung. Und zwar, weil ihr den Unterschied gemacht habt, wir machen erst die Sicherheitslücke zu. Und weil Svea das gesagt hat, und dann gehen wir erst zu den Journalistinnen. Warum? Also ich frage es auch nicht. Ich bin ja auch sozusagen Journalistin im anderen Leben. Und dann ist es natürlich sozusagen, also technisch gesehen ist es so, ihr kommt an und sagt was. Und dann muss man euch das glauben. Warum macht ihr es nicht so, das ist jetzt eine Neugierfrage, aber warum macht ihr es nicht so im Sinne von, wenn ihr die Sicherheitslücke nicht hergeben wollt, dass ihr sagt, ihr könnt vorbeikommen und wir zeigen euch das mal?
Das machen wir auch manchmal. Das hängt einfach an ganz vielen Faktoren, wie wir das machen. Einerseits, wie gut wir die Leute kennen, bei Svea ist das nicht so ein Problem. Aber auch, wie es bei uns zeitlich ist. Wir machen das alles im Ehrenamt. Da ist manchmal nur Zeit für ein paar Screenshots als Beweise und dann schnell den Report schreiben. Und ob wir zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir es finden, schon wissen, ob oder mit wem wir darüber berichten werden. Das hängt dann einfach an so Sachen.
Ihr macht sowieso immer Screenshots oder Videos zur Dokumentation. Und wenn sich dann was draus ergibt, ist das das Material, was ihr weitergebt?
Meistens nicht mal so, sondern was wir einsehen können. Ihr seid ja schon ziemlich... Gerade in dem Fall kann man sich nicht vorstellen, dass ich da irgendwelche Datensätze geschickt bekomme. Oder so 0, 0. Hier war es jetzt so, das ist auch in Ordnung. Das reicht auch für so eine Berichterstattung, dass ich im Prinzip sehe, welche Art der Daten betroffen sind. Also Beispiel Medikamententagebuch, da konnte ich dann sehen, ein Patient hat um 8.02 Uhr die erste Tablette genommen, um 8.05 Uhr die erste Tablette genommen, hatte dann abends keine Nebenwirkungen und hat mit dem Smiley mir geht es gut angeklickt. So was bekomme ich dann auch zu sehen. Aber ich kriege halt nicht den Namen und die E-Mail-Adresse.
Ich finde, dass das Ganze sozusagen so eine interessante gesellschaftliche Mieterebene hat, weil das so ein bisschen, also ihr macht das als ehrenamtliche Arbeit und dann ist es aber eigentlich sozusagen, wenn man einen Effekt haben will, gesellschaftliches Gesundes, habt ihr ja genauso gesagt, dann muss man eben zu den Medien gehen. Das finde ich total interessant slash schlimm, weil eben die, also man würde ja denken als Sicherheitsforscher, macht man Sicherheitsforschung und wenn die Ergebnisse relevant genug sind, dann kommen sie auch an die Öffentlichkeit. Aber nein, im Prinzip ist es ja schon sozusagen damit auch Teil der Aufgabe, irgendwie zu finden, ist das eine Geschichte, eine Story sozusagen daraus zu drehen und also nicht zu drehen, im Sinne von, dass man das journalistisch erzeugt, das auch schreibt, aber überhaupt diese Arbeit nochmal zu haben. Und darum gibt es ja auch irgendwie, da gab es eine Diskussion, wie war denn das? Es gab eine Sicherheitslücke, die hieß Heartbleed, kann das sein? Und da wurde dann darüber diskutiert, wie wir als Gesellschaft soweit gekommen sind, dass wir Sicherheitslücken nur noch beachten, wenn sie auch eine geile Story im Hintergrund haben. Macht euch das Sorgen. Also auch im Hinblick von sozusagen für jede Sicherheitslücke, die auch eine geile Story hat, gibt es 10, 40, 100.000, die das eben nicht haben und deswegen auch untergehen?
Also, ich mein, ganz so kritisch sehe ich das nicht. Also ich glaube, wir würden auch, wenn wir einfach nur einen Blogpost schreiben, damit Leute erreichen. Also ich glaube, man braucht nicht zwangsläufig immer diese gute Story.
Aber dann müsstet ihr auch einen Blogpost schreiben.
Genau, also ich meine, wir müssen natürlich irgendwie darüber kommunizieren. Ich mein, das sehen wir halt auch als Teil unseres Jobs in einer gewissen Form als zivilgesellschaftliche Sicherheitsforschenden. So funktioniert leider heute unser System. Das nämlich, wenn wir was machen, das erstmal nicht öffentlich ist. Und ich meine, das ist eigentlich auch ganz gut so, weil die Lücke natürlich als allerwichtigste ist, dass sie immer geschlossen wird. Und solange können wir nicht öffentlich drüber reden. Und ich meine, dann muss das irgendwie öffentlich werden. Und wir haben natürlich als Zerforschung da tatsächlich auch als eines unserer Kernziele dann immer diese gesellschaftliche Debatte zu bekommen. Und die bekommt man gut in der Zusammenarbeit mit Medien. Weil man da die Story deutlich besser erzählen kann, als wenn wir das nur selbst machen. Ich glaube, nicht desto trotz könnten wir auch einfach unsere Reports veröffentlichen und hätten damit auch eine mediale Reichweite. Ich glaube, die wäre nicht immer ganz so groß. Ich glaube, das würden nicht ganz so viele Menschen mitbekommen. Aber weil uns halt irgendwie dieser Verbraucherschutz in einer gewissen Form so unglaublich wichtig ist und das eigentlich der Grund ist, warum wir all diese Arbeit Tag vor Tag, Monat vor Monat machen, eben genau das wir Verbraucher schützen können. Deswegen ist es uns so wichtig, dass wir auch immer mit tollen Medienpartnern zusammenarbeiten und das veröffentlichen und schauen, dass das möglichst viele Menschen erreicht. Aber ich glaube, wir würden auch Leute erreichen, aber vielleicht nicht ganz so viele, wenn wir einfach nur unsere Reports veröffentlichen.
Und die Rolle der Medien ist ja in so einer Sache nicht nur quasi unser großes Sprachrohr zu sein. Also das ist ein Teil davon, aber Svea hat das vorhin schon umrissen. Da ist natürlich dann auch viel mehr Expertise und auch Recherchekapazität drin. Also wir können uns irgendwie die Sicherheitslücken genauer anschauen. Wir können überlegen, warum ist das so? Wir können uns die öffentlichen Informationen dazu zusammensuchen, aber wir haben weder das Netzwerk noch die Erfahrung, noch die Möglichkeiten, die halt ein gut ausgestattetes Medium hat. Und die es einfach da auch auf so ein Thema setzen kann und eben auch genauer hinschauen kann, als wir das jetzt können.
Ich muss sagen, mein kleines Herz lacht ein bisschen. Ich bin ja alt genug, um miterlebt zu haben, dass die Medien in Anführungszeichen immer sozusagen so belächelt wurden im Sinne von die wissen einfach nicht, was das mit dem Internet ist und glauben, das geht weg. Und wie sich das gewandelt hat, finde ich eigentlich auch ganz schön. So, zum Abschluss. Was lernen wir da raus? Was muss in Zukunft anders werden? Wie soll es gehen? Da gibt es, glaube ich, so ein paar Sollen, die man fragen kann. Das eine ist sozusagen, vielleicht nochmal, wir haben schon konkret darüber gesprochen, aber globaler gefragt. Jetzt ist es ja so, also Sicherheitslücken, die so einfach sind, sind natürlich sozusagen, die dürften eigentlich nicht passieren. Aber andererseits, es gibt keine sicheren technischen Systeme. Das heißt, es kann immer mal wieder passieren, dass irgendwas schiefgeht. Gibt es dafür in eurer Wahrnehmung sozusagen, gibt es schon eine Kultur, dass das sozusagen mitgedacht wird? Wie geht man vor? Wo meldet man das hin? Wie reagieren die Hersteller? Oder muss man da immer noch Hausaufgaben machen?
Also ich glaube, da ist an vielen Stellen noch Sachen, die man ändern kann und die man verbessern muss. Also es gibt irgendwie jetzt aus vielen Jahren Erfahrung ein gewisses Set an Regeln, wie sich als Forschende so was melden, wie sie mit so was umgehen. Da würden wir uns natürlich wünschen, dass die Hersteller da auch mehr Möglichkeiten geben. Also es gibt irgendwie Standards wie Security TXT, die halt offene Möglichkeiten geben, damit wenn so was gefunden wird, die Sicherheitsforschung direkt wissen, an wen sie sich wenden müssen. Zum anderen braucht es aber halt auch immer dieses Mindset, was wir viel zu selten sehen. Fehler können passieren. Es gibt kein 100% sicheres System. Deshalb treffen wir gleich Vorkehrungen, damit wenn es schief geht, eben doch nichts schief geht. Also dass wenn so eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden wird, wie du gerade schon sagtest, so was, was wir gefunden haben, sollte gar nicht passieren, so was ganz Triviales, aber wenn vielleicht was Komplexeres gefunden würde, dann haben wir noch mal eine Sicherheitsebene drunter. Dann speichern wir eben gar keine Daten erst, weil Daten, die niemand hat, können jetzt auch nicht wegkommen. Oder dann verschlüsseln wir alles so, dass es die Patientin sieht und die Ärztin. Aber wir als DiGA-Hersteller jetzt zum Beispiel überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, was da in diesen Daten jetzt drinne steht. Und dann kann auch, wenn jetzt Kriminelle zum Beispiel in diese Systeme eindringen würden, dann würden die halt vorfinden, okay, es ist ein Haufen Datenmüll, können wir jetzt auch machen. Und so was immer mitzudenken, das sehen wir noch nicht oft genug.
Und was würdet ihr euch sozusagen von den großen Akteuren, Gesetzgeber, Krankenkasse, Herzen vielleicht erwarten in dem Bereich?
Also ich meine, von den Gesetzgebern würden wir auf jeden Fall erwarten, dass dieses Security by Design, Security by Default tatsächlich durchgesetzt und nicht nur in Regelungen geschrieben wird. Also ich meine, wie wir vorhin gehört haben, die Regelungen werden ab 2023 ein bisschen schärfer. Und aus der DSGVO könnte man auch schon einiges rausholen. Das scheitert dann häufig in der Exekutiven, also in der Verwaltung und in der Vollstreckung der Problemfälle am Ende des Tages. Wir würden uns natürlich eine Produkthaftung wünschen, dass ein Hersteller auch tatsächlich Ärger bekommt, wenn was passiert. Und der dann dafür haftet, wenn so Daten mal wegkommen. Das haben wir auch noch nicht ausreichend. Und natürlich haben wir auch noch ein gewisses Regulierungsproblem. Also dass es heute nicht standardmäßig immer vorgeschrieben ist, eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung, wie wir es sieht, bei WhatsApp und Signal standardmäßig haben für eine Arztkommunikation, dass es die einfach geben muss. Und dass unsere Familienchats besser geschützt sind als irgendwie die Kommunikation zwischen Ärztin und Patientin. Das geht natürlich auch nicht. Aber das ist eigentlich gar nicht so der richtig große Part. So eine richtig große Part ist, dass wir eigentlich endlich mal so eine Vollstreckung der bestehenden Regeln und der Ausnutzung der Spielräume, die die DSGVO bei der Vollstreckung auch bietet, brauchen. Also, ja, die Datenschutzbehörden und auch die BFARM und so, die müssten halt eigentlich mal tatsächlich was machen. Und natürlich haben wir jetzt das Problem mit den Apps, die schon auf dem Markt sind und die nicht entsprechend geprüft wurden und die nicht entsprechend sicher sind. Daher würden wir erwarten, dass eigentlich dieses Fast-Track-Programm erstmal gestoppt wird, man erstmal all die Apps, die mit Fast-Track gerade auf dem Markt sind, vom Markt nimmt und dann die alle nochmal zertifiziert prüft, sind die wirklich sicher, funktionieren die ordentlich, wirken die vielleicht auch und dann die wieder auf Patientinnen loslässt in höchster Maßen.
Ich finde irgendwie unsere Familienchats sind besser geschützt als unsere persönlichen ärztlichen Daten, eine sehr schöne Social Media Kacheltext. Svea, hast du sozusagen in dem Bereich Forderungen, Wünsche an die Zukunft auch noch was?
Also ich glaube dieses Thema, was Lilith eben angesprochen hat, ja ich sag immer, wir haben ein Vollzugsdefizit, das gibt es ja auch in anderen Bereichen, das wird ich total wichtig, also nicht unbedingt, dass man immer neue Regeln schafft, sondern dass man halt die Regeln, die bestehen, dass die halt konkret umgesetzt und angewendet werden und halt zum Beispiel auch so was wie genau diese Informationspflicht, ne, also dass die App-Anbieter, die App-Hersteller dann eben auch ihre Kundinnen und Kunden oder Patienten, Patienten in dem Fall jetzt halt auch informieren. Hey, da gab's eine Sicherheitslücke, da wollte ich auch ganz kurz sagen, bei der einen App, der sagte uns, sie hätten das dann, ich glaube so nachdem klar war, dass wir jetzt auch berichten hätten, sie wohl auch die Patientinnen und Patienten informiert, hieß es zumindest von der Seite. Also ich glaube, das finde ich, ist der Hauptpunkt. Das andere, wo ich denke, da gibt es auch sicherlich noch Recherchebedarf, ist so dieses ganze Thema Transparenz und so Stichwort Preisgestaltung auch. Also kann das wirklich sein, dass App-Anbieter jetzt wie in diesem Fall, in diesem ersten Jahr wirklich jeden Preis quasi nennen können, der ihnen irgendwie in den Sinn kommt. Das kann eigentlich nicht sein und es muss einen besseren Kontrollmechanismus geben und es muss mehr Transparenzpflichten geben, damit eben klar ist, okay, warum soll diese App jetzt so viel kosten oder eben ein Kontrollmechanismus über die Krankenkassen, dass wir halt da nicht in solche utopischen Summen reinkommen, was ja eigentlich wiederum dem ganzen Prinzip entgegenwirkt, nämlich dass es nämlich viel verschrieben werden kann und möglichst viele Leute eine App gegen Rückenschmerzen auch benutzen können.
Dann letzte Frage und nicht alle Abschlussrunde. Ich hätte von jedem Einzelnen gerne eine Antwort, also jetzt nicht nur per Institution. Und zwar ob er der grundlegenden Idee dieser digitalen Gesundheitsapp, ob er sagt, das ist schon was Gutes, da kann auch was Gutes draus werden oder eher so, das, also lieber nicht oder zumindest sozusagen so weit vermeiden, wie es geht. Wie seht ihr das? Ist das was, also wirklich nicht jetzt irgendwie heute und morgen, sondern in die Zukunft gerichtet, ist das was, was ihr vielleicht, oder wo ihr dran glauben könnt, dass daraus mal was Gutes erwächst?
Naja, es heißt ja irgendwie in der Hackerinnenethik immer, Computer können dein Leben zum Besseren verändern. Und ich glaube, das können sie. Und solche Apps können das, eben die Rückenschmerzen-App, die einem die richtigen Übungen zeigt und einen dran erinnert oder so. Das kann viel bewirken, aber halt nicht, wenn man es so macht, wie man es jetzt macht. Nämlich mit mangelnder Kontrolle, sodass das ganze Vertrauen daran verloren geht. Deswegen in der aktuellen Form nicht. In der Zukunft hoffentlich schon.
Genau, also ich meine, heute kann ich digitale Gesundheits-Apps auch niemandem empfehlen. Erst mal davon, wie sie heute alle funktionieren und wie schlecht sie leider reguliert sind. Grundsätzlich finde ich, Apps, damit es Menschen besser geht, eine total coole Sache erst mal. Und ich glaube, dass es da insbesondere irgendwie krasse Chancen gibt, wenn man irgendwie diese Apps tatsächlich auch mit Arztbehandlungen zusammenbringt. Also genau das, was DiGAs heute nicht machen oder was bei DiGAs nicht vorgesehen ist, nämlich dass so eine Therapie mit einer App koordiniert wird und man dann teilweise Hilfe von seiner Ärztin bekommt und teilweise Hilfe durch die App bekommt. Das würde ich mir wünschen, dass das irgendwie besser reguliert wird und dass da mehr möglich ist. Grundsätzlich die Idee davon, dass Technologie uns hilft und kann gesund zu sein, finde ich großartig. Genau, brauchen halt ordentliche Qualitätskontrollen und so. Und dann könnte das auch was werden.
Ich denke, das ist auch ganz unvermeidbar. Also sozusagen die Augen zu machen und zu sagen, nee, das alles betrifft mich, ich schmeiße mein Handy aus dem Fenster. Das funktioniert so nicht. Sondern ich denke immer, die Technologie entwickelt sich. Und ob wir das gut finden oder nicht gut finden, die wird sich einfach weiterentwickeln. Im Zweifel fährt sie halt über uns drüber. Und das Einzige, was wir machen können, ist halt Prozess und Technologie gestalten. Und das ist halt bei den Digas so, wie es im Moment ist, einfach nicht gut. Und daran können wir arbeiten. Und dann können wir es auch empfehlen und benutzen.
Na gut, dann wollen wir mal schauen, was die Zukunft so bringt. Für mich ist auf jeden Fall ein weiteres Thema, wo ich so denke, im Prinzip halte ich das für eine total gute Idee. Aber oh mein Gott, der derzeitige Zustand, das ist nicht schön. Na ja, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute hier wart und so geduldig Rede und Antwort gestanden habt. Das war sehr aufschlussreich. Danke dafür. Und ihr, liebe Hörerinnen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Lasst uns wissen, wie es euch gefallen hat. Und mir bleibt heute nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.